hello friends i'm alana and welcome to
my channel you are currently
watching my reaction to finishing the
last of us part two a couple of things i
need to tell you first uh i recorded
this
two and a half weeks ago or so but
decided that i didn't want to publish it
until the game was out and more people
had experienced it for themselves
however upon editing i realized the
reason that i don't usually stream
or record from playstation 4 if you're
wearing headphones it cancels out the
gameplay audio capture so
i was unable to capture gameplay audio i
did manage to get audio for all the
cutscenes so that is
frankly most of it anyway so that's all
in here i was originally gonna have this
be like three parts and fully cover from
what i thought the end of the game was
gonna be
to what the actual end of the game is
which is like a full hour and a half
but instead i basically edited this into
the two final boss fights and my
reactions to those
so with all of that said here it is
enjoy hopefully
sorry about the gameplay audio oh
i think we're here we're at the theater
i think this is
in theory if the time works out where
ellie is
and of course the door is locked
the last of us part two ladies and
gentlemen a song
of locked doors
i really see this
back away from your [ __ ]
i said back up oh boy
i assumed he didn't die when he thought
let's keep
get on the ground i guess he has killed
a lot of my friends kill me like a
coward
oh my gosh yeah they're really doing
this wow hands in the air i shoot this
one too
don't you do it ellie get out of here
stand up
now shut the [ __ ]
all right stop stop
toss your weapon toss your weapon
i love that performance even the first
time i saw it from ellie's perspective
that way she just [ __ ] throws it i
love it
he did what he did to save me there is
no cure because of me i am the one that
you want
just let him go
yeah i don't know that you need to kill
one of our loved ones in front of her
again yeah [ __ ] your friends
they suck though we like you both live
and you wasted it
so maybe it switches back again oh
oh no you're gonna you're fully gonna
make me do this as
abby [ __ ] this is conflicting
i don't want to do this at all ah
i know i don't want to do it oh
[Music]
the whole first game is about making me
feel protective of ellie and then
i'm gonna have to fight her like boss
fight fight ellie
i mean it's a bold choice man i
definitely feel something
that's for sure jesus
oh i don't want to do it can i kill
myself
[Laughter]
can i just kill myself can i shoot
myself in the head instead
[ __ ] yeah get it ellie
no no get your hands off of her
[ __ ] me this is this is really happening
oh i'm sorry
oh i'll punch you in the face or the
stomach i don't i don't want to i don't
want to
and jerks you're going to fall through
the floor is that what's going to happen
classic naughty dog move fallen through
the world
change up the setting oh look at her
though look at her
i'm proud of you ellie i'm proud of you
look at you [ __ ] go
your boss i'm i hate that i have to do
this to you okay
yeah that's fine that's fine
cool with it and roll credits
i'm so sorry
like i recognize that this is not trying
to make me feel like abby's the one in
the right i
i don't imagine that naughty dog
expected me to enjoy this
oh god it's painful oh okay
oh look what was he doing this whole
time
stop she got nothing to do
she's pregnant
[Music]
good work lev real golden child of this
game
i read a spoiler that uh it's like
one of a handful of spoilers i've
largely been totally unspoiled on this
game
um very few but i read a spoiler that uh
let me see you again
oh i was gonna say dina gets shot in the
face but i keep wondering if maybe that
one's not true oh my god she
because love was there huh wow
is that it that would be a weird ending
more ellie maybe
very pretty
[Music]
oh i thought this was gonna be back in
time but yeah
we're forwarding time huh
i feel like there's gonna be more to
this than i thought that maybe we
actually have like another hour
there he is i knew she had a good butt
i knew it she's always wearing a jacket
i knew it
oh look at those moves these moves
this is probably the first time i've
found their relationship to this whole
game
maybe the first time i've bought that
they actually like each other
it's very sweet working on you're weird
i'm aware
okay okay you're distracting me
okay all right go okay
that was cute that was cute why didn't
you do that earlier
because previously i was like they have
no chemistry again
i'm like the herding master i'm running
sheep
okay i'm cool with it this is listen up
sheep
your dinner awaits you much nicer
content than what i was just doing
baby how'd you get up tiny baby sheep
i feel like something bad might happen
here well maybe it won't
maybe it won't maybe everything will be
fine come on
dude
there's that ptsd
i too have ptsd for that early
trust me
it makes sense
you're not gonna throw that death away
really ever
okay
this is gonna be a ptsd type
hallucination
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
look i was expecting something to happen
it would have been weird if this was all
daisies i think
considering what just happened
i'm sorry and yeah of course that had a
lasting effect
i was just bringing in
yeah i mean it makes sense to me that
would hold up forever
it's [ __ ] up though
okay
yeah i feel like this game is going to
give me like a chunk more i feel like i
thought that i was done a lot earlier
than i was
i like knowing ellie's okay
but i don't feel like we have closure on
abby at all
i don't want to play as abby again
though especially after having to do
that to ellie
i think it would be weird if they jump
me back to her again
of course i mean somebody's visiting oh
dean is leaving
where you been hunting took a little
longer than i thought
who's here uh just come inside
oh he's alive that's quite a bit you got
there
didn't you get shot in the face there
you are
okay come
sit i got something to show you okay
so i've been putting up this gonna be
happy related again though because i
don't want to
be up in that anymore this new guy heard
my story
he told me about a woman that he
traded i feel like ellie should not be a
part of it really
described her as built like an office
tabby traveling with a kid with scars
across
he said they're living along this coast
in a beach sailboat right here
it's like ellie has a good luck i feel
like abby's is probably a bit screwed
we're done with that
i'm sorry well
i can't go
i know she's gonna do it
it's tell my dear
all right
i get it i get both of you wanting abby
dead
i get it i do too it's easy
forget about her you sitting all comfy
way out here
i'll make her pay tell me that's what
you said when we got back to jackson
tommy
yeah she's gonna leave which is again is
dumb she's putting your life at risk
with the same person again who almost
killed
who did kill joel who almost killed
tommy and almost killed dina
but i guess like especially if she's
dealing with ptsd on
i don't know however frequently on basis
she is
she's especially not going to forget
about it but here's the thing
revenge always seems good in theory
but uh generally is not actually
rewarding
hello it's me again present me rather
than
past me playing the game me i just
wanted to add some context for
everything that happens in this stretch
because there is more gameplay that i
cut out to jump to the final boss fight
ellie leaves you watch her leave
and then in a decision i don't
particularly love the game cuts back to
abby's perspective again who is looking
for the fireflies with lev
in santa barbara i felt like it was
weird to shift back to abby again at
this point i really felt like we should
have just stuck with ellie but whatever
it's not a very big segment anyway
when you think you found the fireflies
you call on a radio and as you are
leaving that location to go to their
headquarters
you end up getting jumped by a group of
what are basically slavers
they subdue and take abby and lev we
then cut back
to ellie on the boat that tommy
mentioned she's trying to chase
uh abby once again goes through santa
barbara
it's very pretty encounters uh two of
the people who took abby
kills one of them shoots the other and
um makes him tell her where they took
out
this is after being like stabbed in the
stomach by a tree
like things are not going well for
either of these girls you stealth your
way into this complex
um i actually managed to get through it
only killing two of the gods even
there are a ton of them it's a really
good stealth segment actually uh
you know that abby's a prisoner there so
you're looking for her and that pretty
much
brings you up to speed let's do it
oh wow
jeez
this one's pretty mean to everyone huh
yeah sort of
[Music]
you're gonna cut it down i don't know
what i do here
it almost seems like letting her live
would be meaner
because damn
so she got fit so isn't she gonna turn
anyway
i can't see your bike
this is interesting
i mean they're both just like [ __ ] up
and awful because of the things that
they've kind of done to get to each
other but then i guess like abby
was trying to get to the fireflies it's
sort of unrelated
but yeah they're both uh
both been on pretty brutal journeys
where they've lost people they loved
for sure
i don't know
what the plan is here ellie
[Music]
you're gonna let her go no no you don't
let her go
you came all this way i went through all
that
hmm
surely this doesn't happen
i understand i guess but i disagree
like i don't think
you're in no position to fight either of
you you both had awful stuff happen to
you i get it
but ellie you came this whole way for
this one thing and i
you came because of the pt there he is
i can't let you leave correct
i'm not doing this
she is trying to save a kid though too
this is complicated
no
oh they skinned my boat's all messed up
i'm not gonna fight you
yes you will
he's not a part of this you made him a
part of this
that okay
this is complicated i really don't know
okay
it's all about the way up there's a lot
to weigh up
we're gonna fight
no it can't be like they don't you know
this shows you her perspective and how
the world works but i don't think this
game expects you
ever to sympathize more with abby than
ellie like
you're still always gonna be on ellie's
side
one of us has a knife you know okay so
oh
she's getting caught up i'm not gonna
live through these infections anyway i
don't think
you know okay idiot
this is some dark [ __ ] man
i guess there's an implication that
that love's going to die without her but
that's not necessarily true i do really
care about lev
oh
this is like i feel like one of the most
like visceral guttural fights i've ever
seen
jesus
if abby wins um when ellie dies i
i can't do it alright
you're gonna drown out of death
i guess
oh my god did you just keep doing it
[Music]
jesus
why did she stop
wait is ellie not going to play guitar
anymore because she just lost two
fingers
did she bite it oh my god and you're not
gonna
kill her oh
what let's take him oh man
oh [ __ ] let's won
he's probably still going
i get it she's just exhausted but
i think you should have killed him
i'm not entirely sure why he didn't if
it's just exhaustion and
oh you went through all that
hmm
i feel like that should have been a
choice i feel like
[Music]
it would have been a much more powerful
decision if myself and everyone else who
got to play it actually had to think in
that moment about the weight of
everything about love being there
about what they've both been through
about what joel would want for ellie
[ __ ]
she did those two things jesus i um
hmm
i feel like that should have been a
choice and that would have made you
think a lot harder
hmm i don't know i don't know how i feel
about that
yeah i mean the whole thing and we
didn't
hmm okay it'd be this would be stupid if
dina takes you back
i would be like i don't i don't you
don't get to just go back oh she's gone
left
oh wow yeah i think you deserved that
ellie i don't think you should have gone
at all especially if you want
gonna do it man
i expected that to be a note here
surprised there isn't okay
take all the ought and stuff
[Music]
hmm
and i don't know why ellie's been in
this chunk of time it doesn't look like
she came straight back like it really
does look like her fingers got
no maybe they didn't i can't i really
can't tell
did they not get stitched up he's healed
[Music]
hey
i just love you but so much sorry i know
i'm sorry
ciao coffee
where'd you get that
uh those people that came through last
week
a little embarrassed as to what i had to
trade to get it but
i'm bad
i had seth under control
oh yeah this is their last conversation
and you need to stop harassing jessie
about my patrols
okay
man dana
is she your girlfriend
no
no she that was just one kiss that
doesn't mean anything she just
i don't know why she did that but you do
like her
i love old angels so much you guys be so
hot you just did just get
worked in the heart
i have no idea what that girl's
intentions are but
but i do know that she would be lucky
you're such an [ __ ]
no he's this little sweetheart he's got
i love that he like clearly just i was
supposed to die in that hospital oh
my life would have [ __ ] mattered
oh but you took that from me
didn't expect that
just gonna say i love that he's clearly
softened as time's gone on
should become an old country man
if somehow the lord gave me a second
chance at that moment
i would do it all over again
he loves you man
that's just
i don't think i can ever forgive you for
that that's bad
but i would like to try
okay this game's so sad god
damn
i'll see you around yeah
that's the last conversation i have
hmm
i'm just so sad
it's not like it was ever gonna be a
happy ending the first one wasn't
but just thinking about all of the
steaks and and old man joel being such a
little sweet softy and like i'm trying
to help abby and then that happening and
then
ellie going through hell and losing
everything too
[Music]
man hey i appreciate it when a video
game gives me
such strong emotions because sometimes
video game writing
is bad and
leaves you with absolutely nothing it's
definitely
a lot of heart
[Music]
i really feel like it should have been a
choice i think it would have been really
powerful
she didn't even [ __ ] take it with her
oh
jesus okay um i feel like that
everything should have been a choice
that is my one thing i feel like it
would have been so much more powerful to
make me have to think about that
there it is ladies and gentlemen that
was a lot longer than i expected
i think we've been recording for over an
hour i expected that to be like a boss
fight
god damn i'm just sad now
i guess she just goes back to jackson
and whatever
what was it wasn't we didn't mean
anything
all right well you know for my saddest
outro ever um thanks for watching
everyone
see you guys next time